talk about rings of power oh no yeah
here we go
what do you think about Amazon shutting
down reviews
for rings of power
wow Amazon shutting down reviews of
rings of power is uh very disingenuous
um I I am a fan of reviews on Amazon
I can't tell you how many times it's
helped me pick out the correct product
um and I'm talking not about movies here
I'm talking about just product reviews
it it's very bizarre to me also that
even that
you know being a Critic is such a weird
thing like we you know we find Critic
reviews of things useful reviews of cars
reviews of restaurants these are all
useful things right but when it comes to
to
you know movies television shows that's
where people's passions come out I think
that Amazon shutting down the reviews
for rings of power is
well it's it's in their best interests
but also exposes that
um they're not allowing
potential fans of the show to speak
their minds
I I think I think it's a it's going to
be a mistake in the long run
and I I also think having seen
the shows or at least half of the first
season
at the time of this taping um
it it's
it's really the whole thing was just
ill-conceived from the beginning
and the fact that they really couldn't
endear true Tolkien fans in what they
were attempting to achieve is is really
uh disheartening
but the shutting down of those reviews
is I mean they're going to show if
they're not going to show up on Amazon
they're going to show up somewhere else
they're going to show up in a YouTube
video they're going to show up in a
comment section on a YouTube video or
something else they're gonna people are
going to be able to speak their minds
about how they feel about the show if
it's not on the Amazon website it's
going to be somewhere else so there's
really no way to to completely shut it
down and I think I think it shows that
you know they're fearing the the reviews
of
just regular people that want to talk
about their love or hate for the show
what is pandering to film journalists
well look I could teach a class on
pandering to film journalists I don't
know why that this became a thing it it
kind of evolved but you do see in a lot
of you you see this occur a lot when it
comes to marketing
when it comes to marketing a film or a
television show they'll highlight
certain aspects of the show that may not
be a big aspect of the movie itself but
they'll throw in a quick line you know
they call it sometimes there'll be an
inconsequential character who happens to
be gay they call it queerbaiting right
so you'll get like a character who
happens to be gay who is in a TV show or
a movie and then it's loudly announced
that this character is gay and look we
have gay representation
but the character really is not
meaningful to the overall story
so
I I really hate it when I see that that
Studios Pander to journalists and what
they seem to be looking for in the way
in the interest of getting like good
press for a TV show or a movie
and then I feel like it backfires
because it completely misrepresents the
movie and TV show and then I do believe
that it can turn off the audience
how do actors bully fans
oh
I I find it really sad to see actors
bullying fans these days
um I I first of all I think it's
completely unnecessary
and I think that if they've got time to
scroll through social media
and Bully fans over opinions I think
that's
uh I don't know I don't think that's the
best use of your time I think one of the
best things you can do for your mental
health is just to not be on social media
um unfortunately for me I'm on social
media
for for work for the most part I I don't
really
you know I I don't use I don't use
social media as a way to fight with
strangers
and I I
look if I was running a studio and I
hired Talent the first thing I would do
is have them pass over give me their
passwords to all their social media
accounts they would no longer have
access to them
and I think kind of the less I know
about the personal life of a celebrity
the more I tend to like them
so whenever I see like an unhinged actor
or celebrity go after
just someone on social media who might
have rubbed them the wrong way I just
think that it's they're they're they're
usually having a bad day or dealing with
something the problem I do think with
with actors is
they go through stretches where they
work very hard
and then the other eight months of the
year they have nothing to do
and that time
you know that idle time can be spent
unwisely
so yeah I I'm not a fan whenever I
witness that I think it's I think it's
completely unnecessary and it's just
made me think less of the the person in
question I I'll say also I do try to
when I see a movie that may have
included someone who was involved in
some recent internet nonsense
I try to separate myself from that so
that I can actually enjoy the work for
what it is
um
you know in particular recently there
was a case with uh uh I was kind of
reluctant to see clerks three
you know I I just I've always enjoyed
Kevin Smith as a filmmaker in his early
days I think he was something of a hero
to a lot of people
you know
with clerks one what he did is is
amazing you know he made this movie for
you know 20 30 grand took it to Sundance
and sold it with the contract written
out in a napkin that's a true story
and the fact that he charged up credit
cards and sold his comic book collection
to get the money to make the film is is
amazing
you know it's it's like a real life
fairy tale
but I think Kevin on social media has
involved himself in conversations and
fights that uh I I just don't think he
needs to what does he need to prove
you know it's like he's stalking his own
fans he doesn't need to do that
so I so I was kind of reluctant to see
clerks three I wanted to see it it's the
third in a series of films uh that I've
enjoyed with characters that I've
enjoyed
and I saw clerks three and he got me
he got me I mean there's things that are
kind of cheesy about it I didn't love I
think at some point Kevin might want to
outgrow the
potty humor but
this movie Clerks 3 is a love letter to
Indie Cinema
it's
um sort of his version of Cinema
Paradiso in a sense and it's the best
performances ever out of Brian
O'Halloran and Jeff Anderson the two
actors that play uh Dante and Randall at
the Kwik-E-Mart you know like they're
the they're the clerks and you'll
it's the best acting they've ever done
in their careers and uh he got me
Kevin Smith got me I'm sorry to admit
but it's sad because I think that there
is a huge audience of people who used to
be fans of Kevin Smith that
um have grown to they've they've sort of
moved away from his work because of how
he's presented himself on social media
I try to overlook those things and you
know
and I'm I'm a little disappointed that I
think people are going to miss out on
clerks three
because of their feelings about the
artist it's tough to do sometimes
you know
it's really tough to do sometimes to
separate uh the real life person from
the work
uh
but if you can look past it for you know
indiscretions on social media
uh you you could you could benefit from
that kind of thinking
In fairness to talent to actors and
filmmakers screenwriters fans are just
as guilty of bullying so how do fans
bully artists
well I think I think
I think this gets down to you that the
fact that there are just so few Stars
these days and I think a star is someone
who's on a pedestal
but now we have access to everybody
because everyone for the most part
or someone everyone's on social media
stars are accessible
I mean I can talk to Chris Pratt if I
want to
um I can talk to other
actors who are on social media
and I think this has diminished
diminished
actors it's it's the there's really very
few people I would I would classify as a
star
I would say Brad Pitt Tom Cruise
maybe Tom Hanks but they're just very
few real stars today because they become
so accessible and even their
you know I tend to be someone that just
uh avoids gossip
and you know for years I didn't even
know that Nicole Kidman was married to
Tom Cruise I learned that later
um I feel like if it doesn't apply to a
movie I'm gonna see I don't really care
about a celebrity's personal life and I
think ignoring it will make you enjoy a
movie much more
but
but it's disheartening
that this tool
we're still learning how to use this
tool and misuse this tool
you know for a long time we didn't have
seat belts and cars and for a long time
doctors recommended smoking for your
health
my doctor recommends this cigarette oh
there's print ads you can find them
I think we're going to find out
I think we're going to find out that
social media is worse for us
than smoking
and in some cases you know it's like
holding a loaded weapon you could ruin
your career in a in a tweet
so it's unfortunate we're living in this
time
we're social media
and so-called influencers dominate so
much
I just hope that we learn to use this
tool in a better way
um because it it's really infected
everything it's it's affected
entertainment
I mean the fact that studio marketing
departments care
what a small percentage of people
a Twitter mob thinks about a movie and
will thus make changes in a movie think
about that they're making changes in a
movie because a small percentage of
people on social media
care about this thing when you could
just as well say
here's the work who cares don't go see
it if you think it's something you
wouldn't like
um so
I think being beholden to the Twitter
mob is just the worst thing someone
who's creative can do
so do you think someone would see more
star-like if they're not accessible
because then there's like this mystery
yeah I think we've lost the mystery of
what a star is or a celebrity
you know we know too much about them
including who they voted for in the last
election
which again just you know again just
sort of turns up the heat on the
rhetoric it's it's really disheartening
to see
so if Marilyn Monroe or Rita Hayworth
had been on Twitter
and we were able to see them too just
walking to get coffee or I mean is there
something about the fact that we don't
really know those Stars personal lives
that well because we found it in tell
all books and things later on we got to
know who's who was with who whom
right I I just think uh it's it's
I think I think it's social media has
ruined a lot and in particular it's it's
you know destroyed the mystery of
celebrities and stars
and it's it's also now that it's like
you know it does affect the the content
that's made it's effect affected movies
and TV shows in ways that I don't think
are positive because you're listening to
a small percentage of the audience that
may or may not be a paying member of the
audience